so we used to have this little tradition
in elementary school every April Fool's
Day where we would switch classes and it
would work every time for the entire day
[Music]
I love my dark purple African sisters
but your hair got to be nappy it got to
be nappy baby if it ain't nappy I ain't
happy if I can't grab it I can't have it
and when I see these light-skinned
Brothers It's evidence that they've been
programmed
all these people want to talk about GPT
AI taking over the future my light skin
Brothers you've already been programmed
by white supremacy
and there's a reason that the foundation
of any black community
is the black family you understand what
I'm saying no
heterosexual couples only I refuse the
right to discriminate this isn't a
government program this is private
talking about heterosexual couples
are you talking about it gots to be
nappy Vegas gots to be if it ain't nappy
I ain't happy if I can't grab it I can't
have it and sisters
some of y'all look like you in love with
the weave talk about you want to be in
love with the struggle how are you going
to be 80 African 20 Asian got least
child's hair in your nose no man
Listen My Beautiful Dark Chocolate
purple African Queen
there's a responsibility that you have
to the community
and to my light-skinned Brothers
it is okay to be of the white persuasion
that is part of your history plenty of
our brothers ancestors were taken by the
slave masters I don't fault them they go
are we then
but we ain't finished because the black
struggle is never fiction
the black community it got to be natural
it's got to be if it ain't nappy then I
ain't happy
all right that's advice that's the bar
if I can't grab it I can't have it if
she got a weave then she gots to leave
what is your thoughts of a good man okay
if I had to choose character traits I
would say leadership consistency
and good heart even though that's
that's broad why is that attractive to
you I think it's really important being
a leader as a man for what I want being
a family type of guy someone that I can
lean on to kind of take some of the
mental load of life like it's like I
rely on you I trust your your judgment
and your wisdom but at the same time
like we're doing this together even
though we both have our strengths and
weaknesses we just complement each other
exactly yeah okay what
that you are aware of I think I'm just
like a huge overthinker I think I like
to understand everything and like
analyze it all the time well said that's
my favorite
I love overthinkers honestly there's
nothing better than being with somebody
and you're relaxing and they're like so
what you thinking about nothing
that's not even possible
that's not an overthinker this is more
there has to be more there's always
something aren't you always thinking
preach what you thinking about
what you thinking about
what you think about come on to help me
I want to strangle you right now so
annoying
[Music]
I would say my biggest flaw is probably
a lot of negative self-talk like
everybody telling you no so if they're
saying no that means I'm thinking no
no I mean I'm just gonna be real like
you I feel like everything y'all all
said is like a combo like what I go
through in some ways like being like
very very independent to the point that
like that's a good trade in one sense
but you're not letting anybody else in
because you're just so trying to make
sure it's done a certain way like that I
feel like you avoided the question a
little bit but oh really it was like a
accumulation of everyone's that was like
well I'm saying like I can see that in
myself
what is your longest relationship and
why didn't it work out
he said
you guys aren't gonna like this one and
you might deem this as a red flag but
I've never been in a relationship and
other like women or even men say that
they haven't been in a relationship
depending on their age and I guess
apparently that's a red flag for some
people seeing what's out there and if
it's not matching the person that you're
becoming you always don't want to pick a
person that's just where you're at you
want to pick a person that's where
you're going yeah
always think they doing therapy for your
soul or some [__] nah bro it's just
something about it like what you got bro
what was the problem with turkey for
your soul I don't know whatever lights
get [__] talk about emotions I just
start rolling my eyes for some reason
man I just I get it like I just feel
what everyone here is saying and I feel
like I resonate with the emotion that
you guys are going through and you know
I'm struggling to emotion that there's a
certain sense of self-confidence that
I'm lacking and I want to connect with
myself I want a deeper emotional level
you know what I'm saying that's the
[__] guy
chorus in them or whatever yeah [__]
talk about the values I feel like a lot
of times they'd be like
and then you know the other thing that
biases me is like you know kids who got
Jesus earrings always having the most
amount of premarital sex Jesus hearing
uh he got the cross on the cross yeah
yeah wow that's a g zero to me that's
not a Jesus hearing that's awesome okay
yeah if you have a cross with Jesus is
that weird
yes but it's okay to have the cross Eric
no
foreign
who's like six foot thousand because the
camera appears to show everybody and
this man's so tall he's out of freight
so the camera man said [__] it he's just
not gonna beat the frame it's just what
you have
look
how you doing
[Music]
oh yeah there we go let's do that one
more time
it don't matter we act like they ain't
around
this
I'm not gonna say anything because I'm a
colorist so let me just carry on
you give me a like daytime talk show
host you have like that command of the
room thank you what did you say that
like kind of resonated um she's like
what did you say a lot I said a lot I
love spontaneity but I also think it was
you're very spontaneous I'm not like
that that's okay
you build on that
Hey listen listen
I'm not gonna say nothing you already
said everything that had to be said but
the fact that you're beating I'm not
gonna say nothing you're saying you
already said everything yeah yeah
anything I didn't say anything you did
though how would you say that growing up
in foster care has shaped who you've
become today so my foster family both
sets were all women so yeah so I get it
yeah very strong it's in a sense I get
like you know where certain women you
know where they've been coming from but
I want to ask one more question for you
because this is like your hair is super
fire like I see a lot of girls they got
the straight hair all love to them but
like curls are a Vibe so like what is
your routine for making those things pop
I don't say nothing
I didn't say nothing
just make sure your hair is healthy
prioritize Health before it looks
because Health really shows in the hair
so moisture hydration and then a jail to
seal it all in you heard her ladies
sorry you already said everything that
you need anything it's hard I'm not
gonna say nothing I like to give
[__] the benefit of the doubt
but right now he's making me doubt the
benefits
I'm not gonna say nothing God damn bro
what are we thinking
so many eligible bachelors yeah okay so
right off the bat this is the one that
you were talking to right I really liked
him and his story I really like
confidence here's more calm more at ease
okay and I can see that for either of us
yeah honestly he was someone that stuck
out to me in the beginning as well so
it's looking like we have a very tough
decision
[Music]
light skin worked as magic on the light
skins no I'll give you two picks you
picked two picks
I got with a bun and the guy with the
green shirt there I think it's between
the uh
and the red shirt
[Music]
do you know if he took off his hoodie
he came around to take that
because he likes him
[Laughter]
there's a confirmation bias that's there
but I in all my years of why did you
believe I have never seen all of a
sudden a word don't say well there's
this last Club you don't know maybe
spill his drink on his on his maybe he
spilled his drink on his on his shirt we
don't know we don't know what the
backstory is something we can we could
assume but we don't know
okay here's who I feel like I bonded
with the most
the most
[Applause]
dope my bro
you thought he chose you
she chose me
you know what I feel like I feel like
I'm too nice
and you think
yay let me know like
pause
um so we actually have a second envelope
um so we're gonna go ahead and bring
that second envelope out now
that is
oh
you know would be the crazy reveal what
there's a third [__] that come out of
nowhere and even the audience got played
yeah
I would actually lose my mind yeah yeah
mom and the mom is hotter yeah
you oh that'd be crazy if there was a
third woman yeah the whole video
[Music]
yes I believe you also have a name in
your office
foreign
you know there's a stat out there that
says like vast majority of interracial
kids end up with somebody else who's
also like mixed
so you guys actually picked right
oh I mean yes I would say absolutely I
feel like both of them I had a great
time my recommendation double dates
don't do it that's just me that's me I
hate double dates
like if you're in a relationship and
your homie's in a relationship and y'all
fully dating five yeah early on hell no
no I'm not trying I'm not no I'm not
trying to have no eggs yeah I'm trying
to focus have this I don't want to have
another woman there or I'm saying
something someone takes it the wrong I
don't want none of that just folks I'm
trying to know you first I'm not trying
to throw in another Dynamic but yeah
yeah but let us know there's just
opportunities for you to get caught
blocked there's opportunities for a lot
of them one girl's having a terrible
time on her date so now she's drawing to
drag her friend away right or let's say
you're trying to bring a girl home but
she's just like Oh my days I want to
have to fight nobody to do nothing like
following get out she says no no you I
need to know the dynamic no I'm not
doing that but that's something you do
when you're young in my opinion that's
most of the time or like if you're
traveling you're going somewhere maybe
like you and your homie go out but then
yes it was fun it was a fun video cool
contestants nobody really threw me off
no you know there's something throw some
fluff out of this but I don't like the
flip
it's just
me I don't mind when someone's a
gentleman I just don't like it when they
do like the whole like deep rooted
Soulful life maybe they like that maybe
they think they like that I don't mind
if someone is like that like a lot of
people just doesn't feel genuine all
right so when it feels like a
performance yeah right with the Jesus
necklace and like hey ladies take your
advice from her because she got the good
hair routine it almost feels like
everything was like a yeah brown nose
everything that's what it feels like and
I just when I see people
commercial yeah yeah
well you heard it from her ladies you
know would it remind me of yeah hey
that's fashion yeah reminded me of that
it was like that guy